SPEAKER: OK.
Good morning everybody, or good afternoon
if you're on the East Coast.
This is Michelle Dunn.
I'm in the office of associate director for
science.
And I'd like to welcome you to this webinar,
the BTK guide to the fundamentals of data
science.
This is the one that's sandwiched between
two holidays.
We were off last week for veterans.
We will be off next week for Thanksgiving.
But we have a great talk today.
And it's actually part one of a two-part series
on data wrangling.
We thought that data wrangling was such a
complex topic that it warranted and it really
needed two examples.
We have one today on EEG.
And the next time we meet, the week after
next, so the week after Thanksgiving, we'll
have another data wrangling talk that focuses
on text mining.
So two very different examples.
I'd like to mention that this session, like
all the others, is being recorded and you
can find it at the Big Data U website afterwards.
Most likely we'll have a few minutes at the
end for questions.
And you can put those questions in the chat
box during the talk or as soon as it's done.
And we'll take a few of the questions from
there.
So, it gives me great pleasure to introduce
today Dr. Joseph Picone.
He is currently a professor in the Department
of Electrical and Computer Engineering at
Temple University.
He received his Ph.D. In electrical engineering
from Illinois Institute of Technology, and
has since had a variety of research experiences,
spending significant portions of his career
in academia, in, industry and in government.
His primary research interests are in machine
learning approaches to acoustic modeling and
speech recognition.
Though recently he has also been focusing
on commercializing technology in order to
automatically interpret EEGs.
Dr. Picone is a member of the IEEE, and he
has authored numerous papers in machine learning,
and holds several patents as well.
And then finally he's co-PI on an NIH BD2K
grant titled, Automatic Discovery and Processing
of EEG Cohorts From Clinical Records.
That's grant is a collaboration between Temple
University and UT Dallas.
So with that I'd like to turn it over to Dr.
Picone, and first of all, thank you very much
for coming to give us this lecture today.
I'm really looking forward to it.
JOSEPH PICONE: Great.
OK.
Well, good morning or afternoon.
We're really excited to have a chance to talk
data wrangling to people today.
And we're really appreciative they're hosting
this seminar so that
we can get a chance to have this meeting.
What I would like to do today is to talk mostly
about how important data wrangling is to this
whole area of machine learning and big data.
Data wrangling is defined as the process of
mapping data from an unstructured format to
another format that enables automated processing.
So that's a pretty vague statement I think.
But today, what we're going to do is we're
going to focus on data wrangling of physiological
signals because these pose some rather unique
challenges compared to text data or the other
types of data that you find in a lot of machine
learning applications.
Signal data's always a bit more challenging
because of the nature of the signal.
So we'll focus today on signal data, and particularly
we'll spend some time talking about EEGs.
And then the next talk will focus more on
the tech side.
How we deal with medical reports, and how
we deal with unstructured text data, which
also plays a role in this because we need
both sources of data to actually do automated
data wrangling of these types of signals.
So let's begin by talking a little bit about
big data, and machine learning.
For many years now we've had a fairly well
defined iterative process to developing this
kind of technology, which we might call a
classic machine learning paradigm.
It begins with collection of data.
I hope if there's one message I'll leave you
with today it's how important data is to solving
these kinds of problems, because if the data
is not representative of the problem then
most of the research done is really not that
valuable.
And making the data representative of the
problem is also much more challenging than
what people think.
So we'll talk quite a bit today about data
and they associated issues with data, such
as annotation.
But we begin with data.
We typically select some features and we're
always worried, of course, about whether these
features capture meaningful differences between
the patterns.
We then select some model.
Or we might try many models.
But we always worry, how do we find the best
model?
We'll then go through a training process where
we estimate the parameters of the model, and
try to optimize the model on the data.
And then we'll evaluate the classifier.
And if all goes well that evaluation will
give us insight into the data itself.
And very often we end up then recollecting,
or re-annotating the data and beginning the
process all over again.
We'll also talk today a little bit about how
important evaluation metrics are to these
problems, and how important it is to make
sure that as you optimize the technology you're
optimizing it
on things that are meaningful to the end users
of the technology.
But this is sort of a closed loop process
because we can iterate on this many times.
And the technology today is sufficiently powerful
enough that if we train on the same data that
we evaluate on we can usually drive error
rates very close to zero, which is very satisfying.
But that doesn't mean that the system necessarily
generalizes well to new data sets.
So we'll talk a little bit about that problem
as well.
Other things to think about, often when you
do these kinds of optimizations you end up
with technology which is very application
specific and data dependent.
What's even worse though is that customers
or users don't often completely understand
the requirements, so very often after you
develop the first version of the system you
find out that that's not really what the customers
wanted, and then you iterate through several
times.
In fact, on EEG data that we'll talk about,
we're actually on our fourth generation of
trying to make the system do something that's
relevant to the users.
And it's been a learning process for the users,
as well as for the technology developers.
And data collection is often an ongoing process
that drives the technology.
And usually we like to collect data that allows
us to solve specific problems.
But you really can't do that all at once.
So every year we try to collect data that
pushes the technology a little further.
And we've had an evolution like that in fields
like speech and image processing.
We're just beginning that process in areas
like bioengineering, particularly areas like
EEGs, and such.
So why is big data so important?
I think many of you have probably seen a lot
of press in recent years about the progress
that's been made on some very visible tasks,
such as speech recognition.
In the past 5 years alone we've seen significant
improvement and performance of these systems
based on what are called, "deep learning systems."
It's been a very, very exciting, very active
time because of this.
To put this in perspective, on tasks which
we were scoring 80% error rate-- that's 80%
error rate in the 1990s.
This is a task based on conversational speech
recognition, today we're scoring error rates
in the range of about 7%.
The performance on these tasks is getting
very close to human performance and that didn't
happen overnight.
However that took about 50 years of research
to get to that point.
But progress has been significant in the last
5 years, and that's primarily been due to
the emergence of deep learning systems, coupled
with the availability of large amounts of
data.
systems, coupled with the availability of
large amounts of data.
So this is a slide I want people to really
pay attention to.
That deep learning systems require large amounts
of data.
We can get very good performance with these
systems but we need lots of data.
And this is one of a number of examples that
has been cited in recent years.
Here we have a task where we compare what
was conventional technology maybe 10 years
ago.
Most of the commercial systems were based
on a technology called hidden Markov models.
And here we have a deep learning system.
And on a fairly moderate amount of data you
very often see that these deep learning systems
perform comparably to the existing technology.
But you don't see big wins with these systems
because these deep learning systems have many,
many parameters associated with them, and
they take a long time to train on the data,
and you just need lots of data.
However, when we do have lots of data-- so
when we go from, for example, about 10 hours
of speech data, to about 2000 hours of speech
data, we begin to see very significant differences
in performance between the 2.
So that's good news in some sense, because
it says if we have adequate resources to develop
the technology we can get very, very good
performance.
But this is a very sobering issue for biomedical
or bioengineering applications because it's
very rare that such applications have the
equivalent of 2000 hours of speech data.
And I'll talk a little bit about that in a
moment.
Big data's everywhere.
A couple favorite quotes of ours in the speech
research community, which I've worked in for
many years-- we actually, back in the mid
80s a researcher at IBM, Bob Mercer, coined
a phrase, which has been very popular, which
is, "There's no data like more data."
With new data you always learn new things,
and you always worry about the ability of
your system to generalize so it's always good.
It never hurts to have more data.
More recently you've heard a lot about big
data, and here's one of the more famous quotes
about big data.
Everybody talks about it, but in reality,
when you start looking at the data sets available
in the community for various bioengineering
tests you very often find that these sets
are small.
They may consist of tens of subjects, or even
a hundred of subjects, but they don't consist
of thousands, or tens of thousands, or millions,
that we need to train these big data systems.
And that's something that we're attempting
to change.
Why are we so interested in this?
Well there is a belief that if we can actually
build systems that look over large amounts
of data we can develop new science, we can
uncover new
relationships and dependencies, or we can
improve the ability of systems to diagnose.
And I want to come back to that issue because
that's an interesting issue when we talk about
areas like EEGs or pathology that require
significant amounts of expertise.
So where do we get this kind of data?
Well, in commercially viable applications
there are significant economic motivation.
So in an application like speech recognition
where billions of dollars are being invested
in development of the technology there's a
good justification for creating large data
resources.
And to some extent, since everybody understands
language, we all use it every day, the data
is quite abundant.
In bioengineering applications, however, the
commercial opportunities are not so significant.
It's not to say that they're not important.
They're of course, very important, but when
you start dealing with financial issues and
such there's less willingness to invest large
amounts of money in the collection of data.
So the development of data resources is lagging.
However there is enormous amounts of data
available in the health care industry.
So I'll talk today about a database we've
been building over the past 4 years, which
is known as a [? TOAGEG ?] Corpus.
And it essentially consists of the last 14
years of EEGs collected at Temple Hospital.
We're now at about 13,000 sessions.
Over 16,000 patients.
It's a very rich, very interesting database
because it's pure clinical data.
It's not collected under controlled conditions.
It's very real data.
There's a lot of this data, if we count video
and such, the size is staggering.
But we're able to-- we use about a terabyte
worth of disk space to process the experiments
that I'll talk about it a little bit later
today.
If I take another example we've recently become
interested in digital pathology.
Every hospital has a department of pathology.
Every department of pathology reads lots of
slides every day.
We estimate that there may be as many as 1
million pathology slides read each day.
So if there was a way to tap into that data
we could build very, very large databases
that would fuel the development of these deep
learning systems.
But, of course, tapping into that data is
a bit of a challenge because of IRB and HIPPA
concerns.
And that's really one of the reasons we see
data wrangling become so important.
There's different facets of the data wrangling
problem but creating a pipeline where the
data from these clinical applications can
flow directly into research is very important,
because then, very quickly, we can generate
the vast amounts of data that we need to train
these systems.
Why is big data crucial?
Well, it's very easy to take a very large
database, and filter through it
to find that it's actually very small.
So when we look at specific patient histories,
even in the EEG corpus that we collected,
which is over 16,000 patients, when you look
at patients with specific medical conditions
you start to find out that a very small number
of subjects in the database actually have
those conditions, or share those conditions.
So even though the data starts to be very
large one of the interesting things about
bioengineering applications is that the subjects
are so unique that when you start to do specific
studies on the data these large databases
begin to look very small.
And this is something we're seeing, for example,
with seizures.
Even though we have a large number of EEG
sessions in our data, the number of sessions
in which patients actually experience seizures
is not as large as you might think, and is
actually small on the small side for developing
this kind of technology.
But what's more interesting is that clinicians
often see a small percentage of the total
population throughout their career.
And a lot of their ability to read and interpret
this data is based on the patients that they've
seen over the years.
And one of the reasons I think big data's
really interesting is very few clinicians
will see the full range of diseases and pathologies
in their particular discipline.
They tend to see a subset that's indicative
of the type of patients that they see.
And when they then encounter patients outside
of those norms they also have trouble interpreting
this information.
So it's really important that with big data
we can look across large populations, and
I think, actually build systems that may ultimately
exceed human performance because they can
see a much wider range of conditions than
your average clinician might see.
So let's look specifically at 2 applications,
EEGs-- EEgs are used to diagnose a variety
of brain related illnesses, and the process
that's done today is actually very similar
to the way it was done 50 years ago.
An EEG is recorded for a period of time.
That can range from 20 minutes to several
days.
And then a clinician sits down and reads those
EEGs, and looks for evidence of seizures,
and things like that.
About 93% of these short term EEGs are inconclusive
so patients often have to come back to the
hospital several times, or be under observation
for long periods of time before neurologists
can see the types of things they need to see
to properly diagnose the patient.
Manual interpretation of an EEG is performed
by a board certified neurologist.
That means they usually have to go to med
school.
They'll usually do a residency after that.
And then they'll often do a fellowship after
that.
So before they become board certified you're
talking about many years of training.
And that's why there's a shortage of people
who can read and interpret EEGS, which presents
a great opportunity for automated technologies
like we're discussing today.
But EEG signals themselves are very challenging
to interpret.
Neurologists usually do this by visually inspecting
the waveforms, and looking for specific events
that they think are an indication of abnormalities.
But not surprisingly the interrater agreement
on these localized events is actually very
poor.
They may not catch every event.
They may not mark every event.
Certainly there's general agreement on a diagnosis.
At a high level they obviously diagnose the
patients properly, but at a low level there's
a lot of room for interpretation of these
events.
And that's what makes this a very challenging
problem from a machine learning standpoint,
is we're actually trying to replicate the
craft that neurologists use to read these
and interpret these EEGs.
And it's very difficult to codify that with
algorithms.
So deep learning, again, provides a very interesting
opportunity for us, in that we hope these
algorithms are capable of automatically learning
some of this information from the signal rather
than having to build an expert system that
tries to replicate the way neurologists actually
do this.
If we look at a similar application, surgical
pathology, this is an application that's beginning
to pick up a lot of momentum in the community,
because it's viewed as a nice application
of machine learning technology.
It's a very big operation, because every hospital
that does surgery essentially has a pathology
lab running 7 by 24.
It takes a significant amount of schooling
to be certified to interpret these pathology
slides, and therefore, again, there's a shortage
of people who can do this.
The benefits of this are obvious.
We can do remote diagnosis.
We can automate this process, and handle things
much more efficiently than having neurologists
on call 24 hours a day.
But it's also, like many of these problems,
somewhat subtle.
There's a large number of cases, you could
say, that are sort of textbook-ish, but it's
not uncommon that a neurologist will call
in other neurologists when they see something
that they're not familiar with, or is outside
of the norm of what they're used to seeing
on an everyday basis.
So what we're going to talk about next for
a few slides is this problem of real time
automatic interpretation of EEG.
So what that means, in a nutshell, is you
take a signal, and you automatically label
it for events, which are deemed to be important
by neurologists.
So here we're showing the ability to label
particular channels with events, and then
we can also make some kind of summary judgment
about the event.
The types of things you look for can very.
We'll talk a little bit about seizures.
And we'll talk a little bit about signals,
like spikes.
Real time seizure detection is a very big
need in this area because very often patients
will be under observation in an ICU, or an
epilepsy monitoring unit, and they'll be there
for long periods of time, and they'll be under
constant observation, but neurologists won't
be available to actually read and interpret
the EEGs in real time.
So there's a great opportunity for real time
detection because that will allow neurologists
to better treat their patients, because they're
getting notified more quickly when seizure
events, and things like that occur.
But detection of seizures is very challenging.
And most of the commercial technology today
false alarms at such a high rate that neurologists
and clinicians simply turn off the real time
alerting.
And this is a problem that's gained a lot
of interest in the past few years because
there's so many automated systems in hospitals
producing real time alerts, and so many of
them false alarm at such a high rate that
physicians and care providers essentially
ignore all of these real time alerts.
So if you can do seizure detection reliably
with a low false alarm rate that would be
a very significant advance in the field.
What things we're trying to do in this context,
we're trying to identify the start and stop
time of the signal.
We're trying to identify which channels it
occurred on so we can localize that to the
portion of the brain where it's occurring.
And then we try to identify a few other things
like the type of seizure that's occurring.
Seizure detection using surface EEG recordings
is extremely challenging because the signals
are very noisy, and real time clinical applications
demand an extremely low false alarm rate.
This is much below what current machine learning
systems are capable of but ideally they would
like one false alarm every eight hours, which
is a very, very aggressive goal.
When we talk about other types of events that
we'd like to automatically label in the signal,
here's an example of some of them.
Spikes and sharp waves, GPEDS, PLEDs, and
such.
We also have a number of artifacts that we
have to be able to ignore.
Things like eye movements.
And building algorithms to do this requires
the signals be labeled with these kinds of
events,
but of course, if there's poor going interrater
agreement amongst experts on when these events
are occurring, that creates a problem that
you don't have the gold standard annotations
of the data that you need to produce high
performance systems.
Clinical data contains many artifacts that
can be easily interpreted as spikes.
This is why false alarm rates are so high
with some of these systems.
Manually reviewing the data is time consuming.
And in ICU applications the need to analyze
the data in real time is very important.
Performance requirements for this application,
ideally, would be detection rates above 95%,
and false alarm rates below 5%.
And we do have technology which is approaching
those levels of performance now.
That's one of the things we've been able to
build over the past few years.
So we think the technology is getting to the
point where it's clinically [INAUDIBLE].
So how do we do this?
Well most machine learning systems go through
a fairly standard process of converting the
signal to some kind of feature description.
We then use those that system then to spot--
we do a first pass at decoding where we spot
events, then we apply a second pass of decoding,
which attempts to look at sequences of those
events, and throw out the outliers, do a little
bit of smoothing, a little bit of post-processing,
and then we do a 3rd level of post-processing.
Sometimes these 2 levels are combined.
But the general idea is you take these raw
event outputs, and you try to post process
them with a system that's capable of understanding
the context in which these events occur, and
interpreting them more accurately.
The current system that we've developed, which
operates close to human performance on this
task, uses a mixture of hidden Markov models,
and deep learning.
We're in the process replacing the hidden
Markov model portion of that with a deep learning
component.
But generally speaking, [INAUDIBLE] the size
data sets that we have the performance differences
between most of these different types of machine
learning systems is pretty small.
It really is more a function of the definition
of the problem itself, and how the data is
annotated, in terms of the performance that
you measure.
Arguing about what's a seizure, what's not
a seizure, what's an important or relevant
seizure, and so forth.
So let's now begin to talk a little bit about
data wrangling.
So we want to build a system that's able to
do this.
And in a perfect world we would have data
that was annotated at a very fine level so
that we could build what are called supervised
machine learning systems.
Systems that learn how to map data to the
answers that you want, and you've got very
high quality annotations that allow you to
do that.
unfortunately there's a whole slew of issues
with this kind of data that have to be dealt
with before you can get to that point.
So the easy stuff-- we like to say, sort of,
this easy stuff-- first and foremost we have
an anonymization issue.
As many of you probably know in dealing with
health care related data, you have to preserve
the anonymity of the patients, and such.
With some data that's relatively simple.
With text data, for example, you can remove
patients names, and patient information if
the data is structured, and things like that.
With some data that's very difficult.
We have, for example, videos of patients,
which while they're EMU or ICU, under observation
with the EEGs, in addition to collecting the
EEGs, they also collect video.
Well we can't really-anonymizing the videos
be very expensive, and therefore we can't
really release the video.
Yet we know that neurologists use both video
cues, and signal cues to determine if a patient
is having a seizure.
But anonymization of the video is virtually
impossible.
Anonymization of the signal data is not so
bad.
We can develop scripts to, and processing
systems to do that.
But it's also time consuming.
With our EEG data, for example, we've had
to manually go through each and every EEG
report and remove names, and things like that,
so that the data is anonymous.
That's a very time consuming process.
We can [AUDIO OUT] some of it in an automated
way with natural language processing.
But just to be on the safe side we have to
manually review every piece of text data before
it's released into the public domain.
But that's, sort of, I would say, in the scheme
of things a relatively easy part of the problem.
Then it gets more interesting when you talk
about the signal data itself.
So, EEGs are a multichannel signal.
Electrodes are placed around the head, and
you collect the electrical signals associated
with these electrodes.
But, of course, there's not a single configuration
that people use, and there's not a single
way in which that configuration is administered.
There's actually several ways in which they
administer EEGs, including what they use as
a reference point for voltages.
Whether they-- difference in signals, and
so forth.
Neurologists, when they view the data, prefer
to view the data in a differential mode where
they subtract the voltages collected from
2 channels.
And there are several montages which are popular.
One of the ones that they like to use for
seizures is a montage called the TCP montage.
So in addition to the raw data, they will
often not view the raw data directly, but
they'll view differences in the channels,
and there's lots of variance to these things.
Even something simple, like the channel labels
are not standard across institutions.
So it's very difficult sometimes to even tell
which channel corresponds to which electrode.
And that can
vary from technician, that can vary by hospital,
and any kind of automated data wrangling process
has to somehow comprehend that.
The channel identity is important because
it does allow us to spatially localize events.
So the technology needs to be robust to all
these types of operational variations.
And we can do some things to automate this.
And we're having some success.
For example, at operating without the need
to use a montage.
We can do some of the filtering and such fairly
automatically.
We can pair up channels fairly well.
But very often the voltage reference points
used to collect the EEGs play a pretty significant
role in the data itself.
And that's a little bit hard to adapt to automatically.
So another solution is to build models for
each of these configurations that you expect
to see.
And that's often what a lot of the commercial
providers do.
Is they just have systems that are tuned to
the particular configurations that their customers
are using.
And then there's also artifact removal.
There's a lot of different artifacts that
occur, because the signals are so low in voltage,
and they're so sensitive, you often get a
lot of artifacts in the data.
Whether that's due to things like patient
movements, or electrical issues, like grounding
and such, or electrical issues like 60 cycle
noise, and things.
You have to remove all of these.
Otherwise your algorithms are going to false
alarm on these events, and call them seizure
type events So there's a fair amount of pre-processing
that goes into the data, and that's often
done through a mixture of filtering, and in
some cases, more sophisticated noise reduction
signal processing.
We actually build specific models of these
events, such as eye movements, and things
and as part of the pattern recognition process
we identify those as eye movements and then
we're able to ignore them.
That's a much better strategy than trying
to build more classic systems that try to
filter these signals, or try to operate on
the waveforms with some kind of heuristics
to remove these types of artifacts.
But most commercial systems do a fair amount
of artifact removal, and the neurologists
rely on that to be done before they begin
to interpret that EEGs.
So let's next talk a little bit about feature
selection.
Most EEGs are analyzed based on waveforms,
but there has been a growing use of frequency
domain visualizations in recent years.
In areas like speech recognition we've used
frequency domain representations for many,
many years, going back all the way to the
1950s and 60s.
It's interesting that it's just
beginning to appear in the EEG community.
So here I'm showing actually the onset of
a stroke.
And we have the wave forms as well as the
frequency domain representations of that.
And if you look closely enough at the spectra
you can see the EEGs emerging in areas, emerging
in the signal about here.
So one when you're developing features one
of the first things you have to ask is, where
does the information manifest itself?
And in the early days of digital signal processing
we would spend a lot of time trying to develop
algorithms that focused on the specific areas
of the time domain signal, or the frequency
domain signals, to extract the kind of information
we thought was relevant in this process.
So for example in speech recognition systems
and in image recognition systems we use a
combination of frequency domain features,
and time domain features.
In speech recognition, for many years, we
used what's known as a filter based approach,
based on some kestral features.
And we also threw in time domain energy, and
then we took those features, and differentiated
them twice, and built a fairly large feature
vector that contained estimates of the time
domain signal, estimates of the frequency
domain signal, and derivatives and so forth.
In EEGs we actually can do something similar.
We actually use a very similar filter bank
approach with EEGs because we know that different
frequency ranges correspond to different activities
in the brain.
And we actually use a front end that's very
similar to what we used in speech recognition
based on kestral features, and filter banks.
But deep learning systems are increasingly
performing this kind of analysis within the
neural network framework itself.
And this has been one of the more exciting
aspects of this research, is that we now have
deep learning systems that take as input samples
of the signal, or pixel values from the images,
and the feature extraction process is actually
being done inside the deep learning system.
So this is a process which is known as a stacked
auto-encoder.
There's, of course, several variants of these.
But the idea is that we use a hierarchy of
artificial neural networks.
And these networks are trained on the data
so that they learn features that are very
specific to the data, and they actually learn--
you could say, in a sense, they optimize the
features.
An advantage of this approach is that the
features are optimized as part of the training
process, so I don't have to invent or deduce
some kind of mathematical mapping of the signal
to features.
The system actually learns as part of the
training process the optimal way to do that.
In fact, the system can learn how to both
represent and discriminate with the features.
You can do, for example, discriminative training
of features as a natural part of how we do
this inside of a deep learning system.
The learning process is also unsupervised
so we don't necessarily need annotated data
for this.
So we can process large amounts of data through
this process, and we can arrive at features
which work pretty well across large populations.
And we really didn't have to do any manual
interpretation of the data.
This can all be done in an automatic way so
you can transfer this kind of a concept from
domain to domain, or application to application,
without the need for a lot of expert knowledge
on those specific signals.
So this is a really good thing from an automated
data wrangling point of view, because I don't
need to have expertise in each discipline
that I'm trying to use this kind of modeling
technology for.
So the feature extraction is certainly one
of the problems that is fairly well in hand
with this kind of technology.
Now, as I mentioned at the beginning of the
talk, one of the things that's really happened
in the field in recent years is that these
so-called, "deep learning" approaches have
been really making vast inroads in terms of
providing state of the art performance.
Deep neural networks are essentially similar,
in concept, to the neural networks that were
used many, many years ago but they have many
more layers, and they have many more nodes.
The architectures themselves have been slowly
evolving now that we have the ability to train
and develop these systems.
So one particular network that's very popular
these days is the bi-directional long short
term memory nets, or BLSTM as they're called.
And this is one of the networks that seems
to be delivering state of the art performance.
There's many proposed architectures for these
systems.
There are probably, easily, 50 popular architectures
out there today, and each one seems to work
well on a specific set of applications, but
the one that works best for a particular applications
seems to be very application dependent.
Though BLSTM seems to be working well across
speech, and video, and a few other types of
signals like that.
These systems contain many levels in many
nodes.
We're talking about millions of parameters.
Tens of millions of degrees of freedom.
And that is one of the reasons
why we need large amounts of data to train
these systems, because they're very, very
large, in terms of the parameter counts.
For many years we envisioned these systems
but we really could not get them to train
properly.
And that has been a significant obstacle until
about 2005, in the past decade, or so, techniques
emerged that allowed these deep networks to
be trained properly, and to reach good solutions.
And that's really when deep learning started
to take off, about the mid-2000s.
Training techniques began to emerge that allowed
these deep networks to actually converge to
proper solutions.
We used, in training systems an iterative,
or gradient descent approach.
So these systems will typically be trained
through thousands of iterations, and that's
a very computationally expensive process.
Since these systems have so many degrees of
freedom they need large amounts of data.
Otherwise they have a tendency to over train
So on small data sets these kinds of very
complex systems can give very, very good performance
but then may not generalize well to data that
the system has never seen before.
The advantage, of course, is that you're self-organizing
the data, using these kinds of approaches,
so there's a potential for new scientific
insights based on what these networks are
actually learning.
The disadvantage though, of these deep networks
is that they're computationally very intensive,
and they require highly optimized code, and
often, special processors to be
SPEAKER: Practical for even medium sized data
sets.
So when you want to train one of these systems
on, for example, the thousands of hours of
speech data, that I referred to earlier, these
systems can require thousands of processors,
and can run for days at a time to train.
So the other, I think, piece of this story
with deep learning is we finally have vast
computational power that's inexpensive enough
that lots of researchers have access to it,
and that's really allow the field to take
off.
The use of special processors such as GPUs
has made these systems computationally feasible,
and that's one of the reasons why you see
so much work in this area now.
Finally the compute resources are available
so that these systems can be applied without
having to have a supercomputer.
But through this process, I want to come back
to this issue of annotation of data.
Unsupervised training is really critical in
this field because you don't really have data
which is annotated the
way you would really like.
If the world were perfect we'd have lots of
EEG data annotated at the event level, localized
in time.
But we never really have that.
All that we actually have is a report.
And I'm showing an example of a report here.
These reports are essentially unstructured
text.
Even in today's EMR, electronic medical records
systems, a lot of the data still aren't structured,
and the language that's used is indirect,
and purposefully defensive.
So they will say things like, "shows indications
of," rather than stating clearly, yes or no,
patient has a particular syndrome.
So the report structure has evolved over time.
Our data that was collected over 14 years
has at least 6 different formats for these
reports.
And the temporal events, you'll notice, are
not annotated or localized.
In fact, in these reports when they say there
is a 10 hertz alpha rhythm, that's actually
not quite accurate.
If you actually measure the frequency of the
rhythm it will be different than that.
This is a observation they make based on a
very crude temporal measurement of the signal.
So even when they provide numerical data in
these reports there's a good chance that the
data is not actually accurate.
So fully supervised training is not possible
because we just don't have the information
that we need in these reports to train the
systems.
This is another big part of the data wrangling
problem, is that you want to be able to build
systems when you don't have large amounts
of annotated data.
So what we used in this case is an active
learning approach, where we iteratively are
able to learn the structure of the data with
very minimal amounts of annotated data.
We start with a small amount of hand labelled
data that usually comes from an expert.
And then we bootstrap the process.
We take that data, we build some models.
We process the data.
We identify data which we have high confidence
in, data which we have low confidence in,
and then we adjust the models based on that
data, and go back and retrain.
And we integrate so that the system gets better
and better at identifying the data that we
have high confidence in.
But we're also able to take the data that
we have low confidence in, and use that to
adjust the performance of the system by teaching
it to learn more about the data that it has
trouble recognizing.
Sometimes that's done through a human intervention.
Sometimes we have to have an expert
review that data and decide which data is
within class, and which data is out of class.
Sometimes we can do that fully automatically.
But almost all systems have to do some amount
of this if you want to be able to bootstrap
up to the very large amounts of data that
you'd like to process through the system,
because it's rare that you have thousands
of hours, or tens of thousands of hours of
data that's fully annotated.
Now, one other topic I wanted to briefly mention
was that channel normalization, and adaptation
are also things which are important to this
problem.
Some physiological systems, like EEGs are
collected under relatively controlled conditions,
so you don't have to worry about the channel,
or the nature of the analog data varying that
much.
But even within EEGs, depending on the electrodes,
the technician, the electrical wiring systems,
you can see systematic variations in the data,
and these kinds of variations are very damaging
to statistical learning systems.
So we have adaptation approaches that can
do this type of channel normalization and
adaptation, and we do make use of those so
that we can automatically ingest data and
be able to process it in a common framework.
Today we do that using a same type of deep
learning approach that we use for classification.
We're learning a mapping of the signals from
these different recording environments, we're
able to map them into such a way that they
can be directly compared.
And that's another example of a data wrangling
problem that's very challenging is you have
to be able to normalize your data so that
it all can be evaluated in a common framework.
So, in summary big data can be transformative.
There's many areas of bioengineering where
we have somewhat of an artisan mentality.
We have experts who have been trained by practice,
and they view their craft as being important
because they've spent many years acquiring
this expertise.
But we believe that we can improve on this
by providing the kind of input we can generate
from these statistical modeling systems.
We can also personalize patient care.
We can also inform patients and health care
providers with best practices, which are validated
over world wide data resources.
That's something that's not happening in many
areas of medicine right now.
We can also impact training and certification
because we can provide students with searchable
archives of data.
Deep learning can play an important role in
this but of course data wrangling becomes
critical because that's the only way we can
create the large data sets that are needed
to be able to train and develop
these large models.
And robust parsing of unstructured data is
critical, as I mentioned, since diagnoses
and reports are largely entered as unstructured
text.
So the companion talk that will be on December
2nd is going to deal with natural language
processing of these medical reports, and how
we actually are able to bring structure to
these reports so that we can use it to inform.
the training process.
But ultimately even when you develop these
kinds of systems it's really important that
the technology positively impacts quality
of care, efficiency, and costs.
So we still have to spend a lot of time working
with health care providers to understand how
they actually make decisions and how they
use this technology in making those decisions.
And that's still a very important piece of
this.
As I mentioned, with our EEG project, we're
now in our fourth generation of what we thought
neurologists need, in terms of a decision
support tool.
And I think now we're getting onto something
which is really useful.
But it was very hard to initially talk to
them, and get that information.
It required working closely with them, over
a long period of time, trying to understand
exactly how they do their work, and what the
gaps were, and what the technology gaps were
in that work.
So with that, I think I'll open the floor
to questions.
SPEAKER: So Dr. PIcone, thank you so much
for such a clear and wonderful talk, which
was incredibly informative.
We do have quite a few questions already that
have come in.
The first one that I want to pose to you is
about how might a patient donate EEG data
to your database?
But more generally, what difficulties, if
any, may arise from bringing in data from
other sources, whether it's donated from across
the country, or whether you're bringing in
another set from a wholesale, from another
hospital system?
JOSEPH PICONE: Yes.
I have the same questions.
So, we have been trying to get hold of data
for EEGs, and that's been a very interesting
process because a lot of institutions are
very protective of their data for a variety
of reasons, including HIPPA type issues.
We are in the process of actually building
a seizure detection subset of this data, that's
going to be annotated by multiple neurologists,
and is going to include data from multiple
sites.
So we're going to be able to answer those
questions in a much more detailed way probably
within about 3 to 4 months.
We believe signal like EEG, from what I've
seen, it's collected
under fairly controlled conditions, and most
hospitals use 1 of 2 systems.
So there's not a lot of variation in the way
this data is collected.
But with other types of applications, like
digital pathology, for example, there's a
big variation in the way slides are prepared
and digitized.
And that's one of the reasons we want to work
in that area next.
We really want to understand how we can do
data wrangling when the data is much more
variable from hospital to hospital.
SPEAKER: It sounds like there are a lot of
challenges there.
So the next questions are about deep learning
in particular.
Let me start with the one the more general
ones.
How would you define or characterize deep
learning machine learning systems, and contrast
them with other types of machine learning,
apart from their need for big data?
JOSEPH PICONE: Yeah, that's a-- so there are,
I think if we look at the space of machine
learning there are, of course, parametric
models, non-parametric models, there are models
that have a small number of parameters, and
there's models that have large numbers of
parameters.
I would tend to call deep learning systems
that are architected as directed graphs of
very simple computational units.
So those units could be simple things like
a weighted sum of its inputs, followed by
some kind of non-linearity.
That's the classic artificial neural network.
But you have lots of these very simple nodes.
In the past, with neural networks in particular,
when we had 3 layer networks, those were fairly
well known, and those existed before deep
learning took off.
When people talk about deep learning today
they're talking about networks that have far
more than 3 layers, and have millions of parameters
associated with them.
And I think that's the big distinction.
We had what were called multi-layer perceptrons
many years ago, but they were simply 3 layer
networks.
Totally general in what they could learn,
but they were not as many levels, or as deep,
vertically so to speak, as the systems that
are being trained today.
SPEAKER: And I also just want to add to the
person who asked the question that in January--
well no, not January, but after The New Year,
so maybe more like February, we'll have a
couple of talks on machine learning in general
to layout that big picture of machine learning,
with the supervised, and unsupervised learning,
and classification, and regression type problems.
So we'll will see this again, and more in
a machine learning more holistically, later
on.
JOSEPH PICONE: Excellent.
Yeah, excellent.
SPEAKER: Another question is about the mechanics
of the deep learning.
And the questioner asks about how sensitive
the gradient descent is to the initial starting
point, but in addition, how sensitive is it
to the different variations of gradient descent
that are out there?
There are all different types of optimization
we could be using.
Some of which are small tweaks, some of which
are more even more different, but you know,
how sensitive is it to all those different
choices that could be made in order to the
deep learning model?
JOSEPH PICONE: Very, very good question.
So I'll start with a general comment, which
is you don't just pick up a tool kit off the
net, and implement deep learning, and get
state of the art performance.
The reality is there's a lot of heuristics,
a lot of anecdotal information, a lot of tweaking
that goes on for these state of the art systems
to deliver the performance that they do.
Most of our work is based on a open-source
tool kit, Theano for example, and we can run
a lot of the packages built within that tool,
and these packages tend to perform comparably
on the data that we have.
But once you start getting deep into the research,
and tweaking them, you can make them do a
little bit better.
With regard to gradient descent, and type,
I was formerly of the impression that there
wasn't much difference.
We had seen comparable performance across
a lot of different configurations.
But recently with these LSTM networks we have
been seeing some significant improvement in
performance using a particular set of training
techniques, and I can talk offline about what
those are.
But generally you're talking about a 10% relative
reduction in error rate.
So our system goes from about 70% accuracy
to 80% accuracy using what you might say are
best practices, in terms of training.
That is, in some ways, you could say substantial.
But the problem with both those systems is
the false alarm rate is still 2 orders of
magnitude higher than it needs to be.
So that's sort of in the noise compared to
the problem we have with false alarm rates.
SPEAKER: OK, but still some improvement is
better than nothing.
So-
JOSEPH PICONE: Some improvement's better than
nothing, and the science in this area is getting
much better.
But there's still a lot of art associated
with training these deep learning systems.
SPEAKER: Yes, and so that's why we need experts
to do this, and to help with this.
JOSEPH PICONE: And by the way, if anybody
wants to contact us, we'll be happy to share
everything we're
doing, and help bring you up to speed on what
we think works well for these kinds of signals.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
I'm sure people will take you up on that.
So there is a question about-- let me just
ask it.
Do you see your model and algorithms being
used in other fields?
I also was thinking about this as you were
talking, because I find it very interesting
how you took the state of the art from the
speech community, and brought in the ideas
about using the frequency domain, in addition
to time domain, and applied them in biomedical
science.
And I was wondering how do you see what you're
doing now, in the EEG and biomedical science
world, do you see any of that being translated
back into other domains, like a more general
speech recognition?
JOSEPH PICONE: I would hope so.
We did some work on non-parametric Bayesian
in models that has been cross-fertilizing
in both domains.
I'd like to say yes, but the problem is, the
amount of investment in areas like speech
and image is so great, and you've got some
of the best groups in the world putting tremendous
amounts of resources in those problems, so
it's been a little bit difficult to keep up
with that in a smaller area like EEG processing.
But the techniques we're using on EEG are
informed by speech and image recognition.
So there's no reason it couldn't go the other
way.
We try not to develop techniques that are
specific to 1 application.
And that's why, for example, we're going to
take the same technology and apply it to digital
pathology.
And I think that we will have some success
there as well.
SPEAKER: Well this is very exciting, and a
very exciting area.
We do really look forward to the [INAUDIBLE]
talk in a couple of weeks.
I think we should go ahead and wrap it up
today, and let everyone know that we can talk
more about it in 2 weeks from now, after Thanksgiving.
So Dr. Picone, I want to thank you so much
for taking the time today to tell us about
this work, and to tell us about data wrangling,
and give us a big picture of it.
And I really look forward to hearing your
colleague speak about the text mining, in
2 weeks.
So thank you, and thank you everybody for
joining us today.
Bye bye.
JOSEPH PICONE: Thank you.